our understanding of the universe
is a house of cards
built high upon a scaffold of
pre-existing theories
and tentative one-off results
and so most experiments in modern
theoretical cosmology
are not as they were in the early days
of physics
they are not voyages of blind discovery
but rather
finely tuned confirmations of
predictions already made
of results already hinted
the higgs boson was first predicted in
1964
and finally confirmed in 2013
just as expected but what scientists
really hope for
are surprises a result that topples the
house of cards and builds a new one in
its place
or totally cements the linkages and
proves the theories
once and for all
[Music]
and so in early 2021 in a laboratory
near chicago
200 virtually assembled scientists
shared a gasp of excitement
had just such a result the experiment
and analysis was the culmination of more
than 60 years work
involving physicists from 35
institutions in seven countries
worldwide
and yet until an envelope was opened in
batavia illinois
and a secretive key typed into a
computer not one of them
really knew what they had accomplished
this elaborate cloak and dagger approach
to experimental physics perhaps more
suited to a star-studded film festival
was necessary to avoid any one of the
hundreds of collaborators inadvertently
biasing their findings towards the
desired outcome
[Music]
this latest experiment at ferma lab was
concerned with the behavior
of muons these exotic particles are the
heavier cousins of the electrons
and exist only for a couple of
microseconds before decaying into
something else
like an electron a muon has electric
charge and behaves like a spinning
magnet
but that spin wobbles when muons move
through a magnetic field
so using the incredibly complex
mathematical tools of quantum mechanics
and the so-called standard model of
particle physics
scientists have predicted exactly how
much the muons
should wobble this theoretical
prediction represents the sum
of what we think we know about how the
universe works
and the elaborate experiment at ferma
lab was designed to test
this theory to find out if we
are right
[Music]
to do this researchers spent four years
installing and calibrating a huge
c-shaped magnet some 15 meters in
diameter with an impeccably uniform
magnetic field
for more than a year they spared muons
around the magnet
and measured their wobble
[Music]
and sitting at the controls of this
machine waiting
for the beam to fire our researchers
would have had plenty of time
to contemplate the theoretical house of
cards
on which their predictions were built
all matter in the universe from the
muons inside the magnet
to the researchers themselves is subject
to four fundamental irreducible forces
gravity keeps the scientist pinned to
the seat of her chair
keeps the huge magnet stuck to the
surface of the earth
and keeps the earth in orbit around the
sun
electromagnetism provides the invisible
pull within the gigantic magnet
but it does more than that it is
responsible for the electric currents
that flow through the equipment's
controls
and for the electrical impulses that
spark through the scientist's body
to keep her heart beating and her
neurons firing
shrinking down further to the scale of
atoms themselves
the strong nuclear force grips the
particles together in every atomic
nucleus
holding them fast despite the repulsion
of their like charges
without this force not a single atom in
her body
the room or the entire universe could
exist
they would simply fly apart in a cloud
of unconnected quarks
and yet in a few thousand atoms inside
the scientist's body
the weak nuclear force is driving such
elemental destruction
the fourth fundamental force is the
agent of radioactive decay
which sees atomic nuclei like the
potassium 40 inside our cells
cracked open and transformed together
the actions of the four fundamental
forces gravity electromagnetism and the
strong and weak nuclear forces are
enough to describe
every single phenomenon in the universe
today
except for it seems the wobble
of muons the revelation unlocked with
the opening of thermolab's envelope
was that the intricate predictions built
on these four forces for the muons
were not in fact correct
muons wobble more than they should and
the results
showed with unprecedented precision that
there is likely
to be something else at play a fifth
force
as yet undiscovered there is still much
work to be done to understand the
significance of this curious
muon wobble but it gives us cause to
re-examine what we think we know about
the four
fundamental forces that we are aware of
our understanding of them too the result
of centuries of scientific revelation
why
are they fundamental to the universe and
are they really
as distinct as we think how
did the directionless quantum foam at
the beginning of our universe give birth
to these
fundamental natural laws
extending our house of cards back to the
very
birth of the cosmos we find
that things looked very different for a
brief moment
of grand unification
[Music]
the existence of invisible forces at
play in our universe
has been recognized for thousands of
years and mankind has strived to
understand and harness them
for almost as long load stones pieces of
naturally magnetic rock
were treasured and used for divination
by the chinese since the second century
ancient egyptians were wary of shocks
from electric fish
and early philosophers experimented with
static electricity
with rods of amber rubbed on cats fur
but these strange phenomena graduated
from mere curiosities
in the 17th and 18th centuries as the
scientific revolution
forced them to yield their secrets they
became the subject of rigorous study
by scholars and statesmen alike founding
father benjamin franklin reputedly sold
all his possessions in order to fund his
research
into electricity it is ironic therefore
that his most famous experiment required
little more than a kite
a key and a thunderstorm to prove that
lightning
was electric in nature
the summer of 1864 was a hot
dry swelter it had barely rained since
april
and in the offices of king's college
london the air hung
heavily in the dim wood-paneled rooms
desperate for some relief from the
baking heat
james clark maxwell staggered to the
window and heaved the sash open
letting in the clamour of the streets
below the air had a sharp and
slightly sweet smell to it one that
maxwell knew
heralded a coming lightning storm and
which we today
would recognize as the distinct smell of
ozone
[Music]
he hurried back from the window eager to
finish his observations before the
coming light show
a trickle of water poured from a pitcher
above his head
for the last time that day maxwell
rubbed a glass rod back and forth across
his woolen waistcoat
long since discarded and held it up
close to the steady stream
as he expected the water bent towards
the rod
tugged subtly by an invisible force a
nudge too far
and the water reaches the rod itself
this
seemingly magical manipulation of the
watery stream
was the work of static electricity the
attraction of like electrical charges on
the rod
and in the water itself no one knew the
potential of electromagnetism
better than maxwell as a child prodigy
he'd spent his teenage years considering
the mysteries of mathematics
and had now turned his considerable
intellect to understanding the nature
of the universe
and so building on thousands of years of
accumulated knowledge
james clark maxwell was the first to
visualize the seemingly magical action
of non-contact forces
as the product of an invisible field
like a three-dimensional web radiating
out from its source
not only that but maxwell saw that since
electricity could produce magnetism and
vice versa
then the fields for those two forces
could in essence be combined
into one great electromagnetic
field as waves propagated through this
three-dimensional web
they carry energy undiminished from one
location
to another visible light is one such
electromagnetic wave maxwell's unique
perception of electromagnetism
as a unification of electricity
magnetism and optics
paved the way for a revolution in our
understanding of physics
as he opened the window to his stifling
office he unknowingly let in a breath of
fresh understanding for all who followed
him
lay down a foundational ace in the
cosmological
house of cards his equations allowed
electromagnetic waves to be produced and
studied in the laboratory
leading to the discovery of radio waves
some quarter of a century later
and providing a framework for
visualizing the cosmos
in an entirely new way
through the action of fields
and so it was that in the early 20th
century albert einstein had maxwell's
fields in mind
as he rewrote the mathematics for
gravity
giving rise to the fabric of space-time
an immense
field that is curved and distorted by
massive objects
like stars planets and black holes
like the endlessly propagating waves of
electromagnetism
gravity also acts over cosmic distances
and
all is caught in its grip to varying
degrees
although our day-to-day lives are ruled
by the gravity of the earth and the sun
the force of gravity isn't actually that
strong
in order to produce measurable
gravitational effects
one must accumulate huge amounts of mass
like the six million billion billion
kilograms
of the planet earth the curvature of
space-time produced by a human body
or an apple is so small as to be almost
unmeasurable instead on the smallest
scales the micro cosmos is ruled by
another
the strong nuclear force
in contrast to the far-fetched fields of
electromagnetism and gravity the strong
force only extends its reach
a minuscule distance no more than the
diameter of a proton
but despite this small sphere of
influence the strong force
truly lives up to its name it is this
that binds together quarks to make the
protons and neutrons at the heart of
every atom
and its residual effects are powerful
enough to hold protons together
despite the fundamental repulsion of the
like positive charges
finally with an even smaller sphere of
influence and a potency
less than all but gravity the weak
nuclear force may seem barely worth
considering
and yet its effects are ones we rely on
for our very existence
the weak force is responsible for
changing the flavor of the quarks that
make up protons and neutrons
transforming one into another to build
or destroy
atomic nuclei these changes when they
occur
inside the hearts of stars fuel the
fusion that keeps them burning
and stabilizes the assembly of heavy
elements thus we ultimately have the
diminutive weak force to thank for the
life-giving heat from the sun
and for the very building blocks of our
planetary home
between them the four fundamental forces
appear to govern
every known phenomenon in the modern
universe
understanding the fields of these four
forces has helped modern physicists to
grasp
model and predict the cosmos with
spectacular precision
but to answer the question of what these
forces really
are and how and when they came to be
baked
into our early universe we must step
further through the force field into the
baffling world
of virtual particles
cornell university nestles close to the
southern shore of cayuga lake
in upstate new york on late autumn
evenings a gentle breeze blows down
towards the lake
to blow delicate ripples across the
water's surface
in the late 1940s richard feynman then
associate professor of physics at
cornell sits
in quiet contemplation at the shore
he is watching the water dance to the
wind's choreography
and he is thinking about quantum
electrodynamics
the patterns on the water's surface
change from moment to moment
driven by the invisible forces of the
wind
feynman imagines a wind field
much like the electromagnetic fields of
his research radiating out across the
lake to create those tiny rippling waves
with enough information he could imagine
reconstructing the wind's field
relating it mathematically to its source
atop the hillside
but to truly understand the wind the
large-scale field
is not enough he would need to know
about the particles of
air that carried the wind's power how
they moved how they interacted with one
another and with the water
of the lake the winds field relied
ultimately
on the particles that carried it could
the electromagnetic field
be similarly reduced
feynman was riding the growing wave of
the quantum revolution
for the last 20 years interrupted
somewhat by world war ii
theoretical physicists have begun to
comprehend the universe on a tiny
particulate scale recognizing that light
waves could be quantized into minute
parcels of energy
known as photons but as james clark
maxwell had shown some 80 years
previously
light is also a wave
a manifestation of the electromagnetic
field that permeates the universe
how could these two differing viewpoints
be reconciled
feynman provided a mathematical solution
in the form of quantum electrodynamics
quantizing the electromagnetic field and
defining the interactions of particles
that deliver this far-reaching force
and its many effects
the messenger of electromagnetism he
determined was indeed the photon
but photons are not physical tangible
particles like the air molecules that
make up the wind
they are virtual messengers
quantized parcels of energy that don't
interact with one another but
nevertheless can be exchanged to alter
the properties of real matter
producing the different effects of the
electromagnetic force
free photons that are emitted and not
exchanged become
visible light and other forms of
radiation
and bizarrely according to the strange
tenets of quantum dynamics
these virtual photons can briefly pop
into
and out of existence even when there is
nothing else around
for example inside a true vacuum
normally their fleeting existence goes
unnoticed
but in 1948 dutch physicist hendrick
kasmir found that when two mirrors were
placed facing each other in a true
vacuum
they would be mysteriously attracted to
one another
the only agent of force could be these
virtual photons
he reasoned that more of the messenger
particles could exist outside the
mirrored plates than between them
and the resulting pressure difference
was enough to force them ever so
slightly
together the phenomenon is known as the
casmir effect
and it is an elegant demonstration of
the energy contained within all vacuums
throughout the universe now and since
its creation
like maxwell before him feynman's new
treatment of the electromagnetic force
once again
revolutionized theoretical physics
recognizing that one of the fundamental
forces of the universe could be so
quantized
physicists spent the following decades
following in feynman's theoretical
footsteps
and seeking the virtual messengers of
the other cosmic force
fields
the strong force was the next to reveal
its secrets probably owing to its
strength
allowing it to be studied in
laboratories as soon as sufficiently
precise instruments could be built
the study of quantum chromodynamics is
therefore concerned with the agents of
this powerful
yet limited force the virtual messenger
in this case
is the gluon so named for its ability to
glue quarks together
to form protons and neutrons but the
message that these gluons carry is more
complex than the simple energy exchange
of photons
nevertheless through theoretical and
mathematical attrition
photons and gluons found a place within
a modern framework of particle physics
known as the standard model under
experimental scrutiny
even the weak force with its tiny reach
and feeble powers
has yielded its own virtual messenger
particles
called w and z bosons and they are
different again from gluons and photons
they are massive with roughly 100 times
the mass of an entire proton
making them heavier than entire ion
atoms
compared to photons with zero mass these
massive messengers
are confined by their own inertia
to date only the gravitational force
evades quantization
theoreticians have predicted the
existence of a virtual messenger with
zero mass called
graviton but there are fundamental
incompatibilities
between the quantum standard model and
our other framework for understanding
gravity
general relativity gravity is a million
billion billion times weaker than the
weak force
making it impossible to probe with the
kind of instruments we can build now
or in the foreseeable future but even
without gravity
the standard model has gone a long way
to probing the fundamental forces
on their smallest scales and yet
frustratingly the solutions to these
natural puzzles
seem far from standard all of the
virtual messengers that we have
discovered
behave in their own unique ways and have
their own
unique properties that render the
fundamental forces
just that fundamental
and irreducible and yet
remarkably and somewhat
counter-intuitively physics today
is painting a more consolidated picture
in which these irreducible forces are
simply facets
of a single unified whole one
which had its origins in the earliest
moments
of the cosmos
professor abdul salam stepped forward to
receive his nobel prize on the 10th of
december
1979 he allowed himself a small smile
reflecting a brief surge of pride within
he was a humble private and modest man
who seldom wasted his energy on
self-reflection preferring instead the
relentless pursuit of knowledge
salaam's genius had manifested at an
early age and he pursued his academic
career in lahore in pakistan
and in cambridge and london in the uk
while working on his doctoral thesis
he managed to solve in six months a
mathematical physics problem that
advects to the great richard feynman
for his entire career his nobel prize
was shared with two other american
physicists
sheldon glashau and stephen weinberg for
a solution that the three of them had
been working on for the preceding two
decades
they had proven in yet another paradigm
blasting moment for physics
that two of the three apparently
irreducible
fundamental forces of the universe could
in fact
be reduced united into one
the weak force with its minuscule range
and diminutive power
delivered by massive virtual messengers
could not seem more different from the
electromagnetic force's infinite reach
a strength some 10 million times greater
and a massless
photon messenger yet they showed that
electromagnetism
is an intrinsic and necessary component
of the weak force
and that these two superficially
different fundamental forces
are merely manifestations of one
so-called electro weak force
salam glashau and weinberg's theory was
yet another turning point for
understanding the physics
of the universe just as the atom was
once thought to be the fundamental
indivisible building block of matter
only to be split
time and time again by advances in
experimental physics
so two of the irreconcilable fundamental
forces of nature
had been unexpectedly united
but in the physical world it would take
extremely high energies
equivalent to a temperature of about a
quadrillion degrees celsius
for the electromagnetic and weak forces
to be truly united to act as one
modern physicist alex filippenko has
visualized this as a coin
spun across a table when it is spinning
fast it is hard to distinguish one side
from another
it appears symmetric and unified like
the weak force
but as it runs out of energy and settles
that unification is broken
to reveal two distinct sides heads
and tails or in this case
weak and electromagnetic forces
buoyed and encouraged by this remarkable
discovery abdassalam
along with an enthusiastic new crop of
theoretical and experimental physicists
turned to the next possible unification
that of the strong force with the
electro weak
this so-called grand unification theory
would seek to describe
three of the four fundamental forces
within the same
framework for now gravity which evades
quantization altogether
is a challenge too far but even grand
unification is hard to prove
theoretical physics has predicted that
it's sufficiently high energy
the distinct virtual messengers photons
gluons and w
and z bosons would cease to exist and be
replaced by a single
unified particle known as an x
boson
measurements of the three forces at
increasingly high temperature
have revealed changes in the relative
strengths of these forces
the strong force gets weaker the weak
force gets stronger
we might imagine that by turning up the
dial by cranking the energy up
even further they will eventually
converge
and become one but in reality
there is no dial we cannot go any
further
the predicted energies necessary for
this grand unification
are some million million times greater
than for the electro weak force
such energies are simply beyond our
reach on earth
or anywhere else in the universe today
even if we somehow harness the powerful
blast wave of a supernova
or the jets from a black hole or neutron
star
these would still be about a billion
times too feeble
and yet there was a time when such
blisteringly high energy
reigned supreme across the universe
for a few fractions of a second moments
after the big bang
the eponymous grand unification epoch
saw three forces combined into one
with truly bizarre consequences
[Music]
near the cosmopolitan swiss city of
geneva an engineer
turns the valve on a canister of
compressed hydrogen
allowing the atoms to stream out to high
pressure the atoms flow through an
electric
field which strips them of their
electrons leaving only naked protons to
fill the adjoining airless pipe
from there the positively charged
protons are subjected to alternating
electric
fields that pull them along the pipe
accelerating them to ever greater speeds
at points radio waves are injected to
give them an additional push
and strong magnets arranged around the
pipe bend the beam of protons around an
endless curve the proton beam is spun
around four successive rings of
increasing
diameter and length building speed and
energy with each pass
at last the beam is split in two and
sent in opposite directions around a 27
kilometer long ring until
with pinpoint precision two fated
protons collide
in a shower of subatomic particles
[Music]
this is cern's large hadron collider
the most advanced and powerful particle
accelerator
in the world the energy of these proton
collisions are on the order of ten
thousand giga electron volts
corresponding to a temperature
of about a hundred thousand trillion
degrees celsius this is the greatest
energy we have created in experiments on
earth
but it is still a very long way from
probing the energies
of the early universe trace are
expanding cosmos back through time and
all of the matter and energy within
becomes denser
more tightly packed and by extension
hotter
and more energetic at the unfathomably
small scales that reigned just after the
big bang
physicists predict that the entire
universe had an energy of 10
to the 16 giga electron volts that's 10
followed by 16 zeros equivalent to a
temperature
of a hundred thousand trillion trillion
degrees it is some trillion times higher
than the large hadron collider has ever
managed or indeed
ever will there is no experiment that
can tell us how the universe behaved
under such extreme conditions
but the work of maxwell feynman and
salam and his colleagues
has helped us imagine how the four
fundamental forces worked
during these earliest moments
for one unit of planck time a 10 million
trillion trillion trillionth of a second
after the birth of the universe in the
big bang
utter weirdness ruled gravity as we know
it
did not exist was unable to exist in the
excruciatingly small embryonic universe
this was the planck error defined by a
seething quantum foam
composed of micro black holes and
wormholes popping into
and out of existence without any
recourse to logic or causality
but by the end of this minute fragment
of time the baby universe had expanded
and cooled enough for the enigmatic
force of gravity
such as we understand it to manifest
gravity may now be distinct
but the temperature and energy of this
hyper-compactified universe is still
high enough
for the three other forces strong weak
and electromagnetic
to be combined into one the so-called
electro-nuclear superforce
during this grand unification epoch the
entire cosmos is still less than the
size of a single quark
and is filled with a sea of photons
which spontaneously transform into pairs
of matter
and antimatter creating the smallest
particles of physical stuff
in the universe they are the quarks
the building blocks of protons and
leptons
like electrons and muons but these first
particles do not stick around for long
the extremely high energies that prevail
mean that these particles are just as
likely to decay back into photons
so over time the physical component of
the cosmos
doesn't truly grow even for the brief
time that they exist
the combination of the three fundamental
forces means that these mata and
antimatter particles
don't behave in any way that we might
expect instead
physicists think that the ex-boson
messengers of the electronuclear force
may have driven the conversion of quarks
into leptons
of matter into antimatter and vice versa
this primordial game of cosmic tag is
the ultimate magic trick
just a tap from an ex-boson magic wand
is enough to turn the white rabbit
into a bunch of flowers or back the
other way
when the forces that define our natural
laws are combined
the universe is a lawless free-for-all
of virtual and real matter
and antimatter quarks and leptons
no one component dominates over the
others and the composition of the
universe dynamically shifts
from one tiny moment to the next
the universe continues to expand and
cool throughout the grand unification
epoch
yet for all the magnificence of its name
this great epoch is over
in the blink of a figurative eye almost
a trillion trillion trillionth of a
second after it started
the grand unification epoch is brought
crashing
to an end
[Music]
the temperature of the cosmos is now a
mere 1000
trillion trillion degrees cool enough
and with energies
low enough for the strong force to
emerge as a fundamental force
in its own right and so the end of one
great age
marks the beginning of another this
is the electro weak epoch ruled now
by gravity the strong force and the
unified
electro weak force despite the emergence
of the strong force the temperatures
during this time were still
so high and the fleeting quarks so
energetic
that this newborn force had little
chance to act
the quarks remained free and unbound and
familiar protons and neutrons
an unstable rarity and yet there was
a change in the overall balance of the
cosmos
with the loss of the super-unified
electronuclear force
the messenger particles of that force
also disappear
the x-bosons decay themselves into an
assortment of matter
and antimatter quarks and leptons
the splitting of the great force for the
first time
seeds the universe with stuff
many physicists believe that it was this
change that triggered the rapid cosmic
inflation
that characterized the universe's next
great error
thanks to the huge differences in
unification energies across the three
forces
the electro weak epoch lasted a
veritable eon
compared to the time of grand
unification after nearly 100 billionth
of a second
the universe had inflated exponentially
had seen the decisive creation of mata
from energy
and had cooled to just three quadrillion
degrees
and only at this point when particle
energies dropped to about a thousand
giga electron volts did the weak force
and the electromagnetic force become
distinct from one another
and the four fundamental forces of our
modern universe
finally began to function as separate
entities
this picture of a unified beginning has
been the culmination of
all modern thinking in experimental
particle physics and early universe
cosmology
backed up by more than 150 years of
revelations
about the fundamental laws that govern
the universe
how then do the recent tantalizing hints
of a potential fifth force
fit in some have suggested that the
finding
undermines the carefully constructed
house of cards on which our
understanding of particle physics relies
others more optimistically hope that the
tiny
anomalous wobble of muons could be the
key
to unlocking some of the more enduring
mysteries of the modern universe
could the fifth force be somehow linked
to the dark matter
that holds rotating galaxies together
against their whirlwind spin
could it be connected with the dark
energy whose effects are only just
beginning to be felt as the cosmoses
expansion
accelerates time
and work will tell
the muon experiment continues through
2021
with several more runs through
fermilab's gigantic magnet hoping to
narrow down the precision of the
measurements
even more the 200 collaborators are
cautious in claiming a discovery just
yet
in their preliminary results there could
be a one in forty thousand chance that
the muon wobble is a random
chance event so before they're sure a
fifth
paradigm blasting force is really there
the scientists are hoping to reduce that
chance to just one
in three and a half million if
and when that happens we will be soon
looking to the future fineman
salam or maxwell for the next revelation
in unified physics
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe
and leave a comment to tell us what you
think thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time
[Music]